ahora que ya estamos familiarizados con
el método de hoy les vamos a hacer un
ejercicio para poner a prueba nuestra
comprensión matemática de este método o
al menos el proceso de cómo se usa ok y
el problema dice así considera la
ecuación diferencial derivada de ye
respecto de x igual a 3x menos 2 y ahora
sea igual a gd x una solución de la
ecuación diferencial con la condición
inicial g evaluada en 0 igual acá donde
k es una constante el método de hoy leer
empezando en x igual a 0 con un tamaño
de paso igual a 1 da la aproximación d
he evaluado en dos aproximadamente 4.5
encuentra el valor de acá y para hacer
esto nuevamente vamos a partir de la
condición inicial x igual a cero y igual
acá eso es lo que nos dice esta
información entonces vamos a utilizar el
método de hoy leer en pasos de tamaño 1
verdad aquí está que nos dice que los
pasos son de tamaño 1 así que iremos de
0 a 1 y luego de 1 a 2 y esa
aproximación será igual a 4.5 así que
partiendo del valor que podremos
descubrir su valor
al aproximar que evaluado en 2 entonces
te invito a que como siempre hagas una
pausa trates de resolver el problema por
tu propia cuenta y después lo vemos
juntos
entonces suponiendo que ya al menos lo
intentaste vamos a hacer exactamente lo
mismo que hicimos en el primer vídeo
donde vimos el método de hoy les vamos a
hacer una tablita ok vamos a poner
digamos
una línea aquí va a estar el valor de x
acá va a estar el valor de g y aquí
vamos a poner el valor de la derivada de
ye con respecto de xy vamos a partir de
nuestra condición inicial que nuestra
condición inicial es 0 acá muy bien
entonces si esta es nuestra condición
inicial ahora calculamos la derivada de
y con respecto de x verdad que es 3x
menos 2 y en este caso x vale 0 entonces
sería 3 por 0 menos 2 veces ya que en
este caso es cada verdad y esto
simplemente nos da menos 2 acá muy bien
entonces simplemente ya tenemos ahí la
pendiente en este punto ahora
incrementamos un salto guardar damos un
salto y nuestros altos son son de tamaño
entonces x será igual a 1 verdad y ya
como es que aumenta pues ya sería igual
ya será igual al estado anterior más el
tamaño de salto que es 1 por la derivada
verdad en este caso como el tamaño es 1
entonces lo que hay que agregarle es
menos 2 acá entonces si acá le agregamos
menos 2 acá tendremos que el valor
siguiente de ye será menos k verdad
ahora calculamos nuevamente la derivada
de y con respecto de x y esto será 3
veces x que en este caso es 3 por 1
menos dos veces y menos dos veces menos
acá y esto es simplemente 3
2k 32 k es el siguiente paso verdad
ahora vamos con el siguiente que sería
aumentar 1 verdad en x y aquí ya
obtenemos x igualados y esto es
justamente el que nos interesa verdad
porque una vez que encontremos cuánto
vale jay og evaluado en 2 eso nos dará
algo en términos de k como hemos estado
obteniendo hasta este momento y podremos
ver que si eso lo igualamos a 4.5
podríamos obtener el valor de cada
verdad entonces si aumentamos 1 en x
sabemos que el siguiente valor de ye
será el estado anterior que es menos acá
y le sumamos la derivada verdad que en
este caso es 3 más 2 k menos acá nos da
3 más
cada verdad entonces esta es la
aproximación que nos da el método de
boiler paraje evaluado en dos verdad
entonces que evaluado entonces tres más
acá y esto según el planteamiento del
problema debe ser 4.5 eso nos dice si
restamos 3 de ambos lados que acá tiene
que ser 1.5 entonces este es el valor de
la condición inicial para y para que
esta aproximación según el método del
método de hoy leer nos de 4.5 es decir
si nosotros tomamos que evaluado en 0
igual a 1.5 entonces podremos
simplemente verificar que al sustituir
todo esto nos da que el valor en 2 es
4.5 verdad entonces con esto hemos
terminado el problema